E
REPLACED.
SO, WHEN YOU THINK OF
BILL GATES, HE'S A A GUY WHO
MADE BILLIONS WITH CORPORATE
SOFTWARE.
BILL GATES DOESN'T THINK OF
HIMSELF THAT WAY.
HIMSELF WHO GOT SUPER RICH.
HE THINKS OF HIMSELF AS GOD.
HE CONTROLS THE SOLAR SYSTEM.
AND THAT IS WHY HE IS BACK IN
SOMETHING CALLED SUN DIMMING
TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD REFLECT
SUNLIGHT OF THE EARTH'S
ATMOSPHERE CAUSING GLOBAL
COOLING.
THAT'S NOT FRAUGHT WITH RISK.
YOU THOUGHT PATHOGENS WAS
DANGEROUS.
SCIENTISTS ARE TESTING THAT
TECHNOLOGY BY SPEWING CALCIUM
CARBONATE DUST INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE.
>> BILL GATES IS BACK IN THE
FIRST HIGH-ALTITUDE EXPERIMENT
CREATING A MASSIVE CHEMICAL
CLOUD.
IT IS CALLED SOLO GEO
ENGINEERING.
IT WOULD LOOK SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
THOUSANDS OF PLANES WOULD FLY
VERY HIGH AND INJECT MILLIONS OF
TONS OF LIGHT REFLECTING
PARTICLES INTO THE STRATOSPHERE.
IT WOULD CREATE A THIN CHEMICAL
CLOUD OF PARTICLES AROUND THE
WHOLE PLANET BLOCKING SUNLIGHT
FROM REACHING THE SERVICE.
>> Tucker: NOW, JUST TO
RESTATE, BILL GATES IS NOT GOD.
WILL GATES IS SOME KIND OF WEIRD
SOCIALLY AWKWARD RICH GUY.
HE IS NOW CHANGING THE PLANET.
THIS IS NOT JUST OVER HIS YARD.
THIS IS OVER YOUR YARD AND OUR
OCEANS ON THE WHOLE PLANET.
NOW, ACCORDING TO FORBES, THE
PROJECT'S TOP INVESTIGATOR "DOES
NOT KNOW WHAT THE RESULTS MIGHT
BRING."
JUST AN EXPERIMENT WITH THE
GLOBE AND FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENS.
MICHAEL SHELLENBERGER IS THE
AUTHOR OF APOCALYPSE NEVER WHILE
ENVIRONMENTAL ALARMISM HURTS US
ALL.
OUR RIVERS AND OCEANS GET
DIRTIER AND NO ONE NOTICES.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
IT'S A LITTLE ALARMING TO THINK
THAT SOMEONE AS MYOPIC AND OUT
OF TOUCH AND TOTALLY IDEOLOGICAL
AND WEIRD AS BILL GATES THINKS
HE'S IN CHARGE OF THE PLANET.
WHAT SHOULD WE BE WORRIED ABOUT
HERE?
>> I MEAN, BASICALLY EVERYTHING.
WHEN I FIRST HEARD ABOUT THIS
OVER TWO DECADES AGO, THIS WAS A
THOUGHT EXPERIMENT.
BUT THIS IS REAL.
THEY ARE REALLY TRYING TO DO
THIS.
THEY'VE ENCOUNTERED OPPOSITION
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
I'VE COAUTHORED ARTICLES WITH
THE HARVARD INVESTIGATOR.
WE TOLD HIM PERSONALLY THIS IS A
TERRIBLE IDEA.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF SCIENTISTS
THE DON'T ACT DISAGREE WITH
THIS.
WHAT THEY ARE PROPOSING TO DO IS
IDENTICAL TO WHAT WE FEARED
WOULD OCCUR AFTER NUCLEAR WAR IN
THE 1980s, WHICH IS NUCLEAR
WINTER, THE IDEA THAT YOU COOL
THE PLANET DELIBERATELY.
THE EFFECTS ON CROPS OR
COMPLETELY UNKNOWN.
THEY CALL THIS AN EXPERIMENT BUT
THEY KNOW THERE IS NO WAY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE LARGE-SCALE
PLANETARY EFFECTS OF THIS KIND
OF THING WOULD BE.
IT'S GROSSLY IRRESPONSIBLE HERE
THEY KNOW FOR A FACT THAT THEY
WILL NEVER GET INTERNATIONAL
AGREEMENT ON THIS.
SO THEY ARE BASICALLY TRYING TO
SOCIALIZE THE IDEA, NORMALIZE
THE IDEA, MAKE US COMFORTABLE
WITH AN IDEA THAT SHOULD MAKE US
EXTERNALLY UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
HE IS NOW TRYING TO CONTROL THE
SOLAR SYSTEM?
THE FUNNY THING IS, ANYONE WHO
NOTICES THIS, THAT MAY BE
BILL GATES OUTSIDE CONTROL OVER
OUR LIVES IS DENOUNCED BY SO
MANY OF THESE FRAUDULENT
FACT-CHECKING SITES, CONSPIRACY
NOT.
DO YOU THINK YOU ARE CONSPIRACY
NOT TO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
BILL GATES?
>> NO.
I MEAN, THIS IS BONKERS.
I MEAN HONESTLY, THERE ARE VERY
FEW PEOPLE WHEN YOU TALK TO THEM
PRIVATELY WHO THINK IT'S A GOOD
IDEA.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE VERY SCARED TO SPEAK OUT
PUBLICLY BECAUSE BILL GATES
INFLUENCE IS EXTRAORDINARY.
HE IS A MASSIVE PHILANTHROPIST.
I THINK HIS INTENTIONS ARE VERY
GOOD.
I HAVE NO DOUBT HE HAS WELL
INTENTION.
BUT GOOD INTENTIONS CAN LEAD TO
SOME VERY BAD THINGS.
THE AMOUNT OF HUBRIS AND
ARROGANCE INVOLVED HERE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS OF
FARMERS AROUND THE WORLD WHO
WILL BE AFFECTED BY THIS.
HOW WILL THEY BE CONSULTED?
WHAT IS THE IDEA FOR HOW THIS IS
GOING TO BE GOVERNED?
THERE IS NO PLAN FOR GOVERNANCE.
THERE IS NO WAY TO GET AGREEMENT
ON THIS INTERNATIONALLY.
THEY KNOW THIS.
TUCKER, THE THING IS THE TRENDS
ON CLIMATE CHANGE, MOST PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE, BUT GOING TO THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
THE UNITED STATES HAS REDUCED
ITS CARBON EMISSIONS BY MORE
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY IN THE
LAST 20 YEARS.
WE HAVE HAD AN EXTRAORDINARY
SUCCESS IN THE UNITED STATES AND
ARE REDUCED IN AIR POLLUTION AND
NOW WE ARE FACED WITH THE
PRODUCTION OF THIS RADICAL
EXPERIMENT.
>> Tucker: TAX-EXEMPT
NONPROFIT.
PEOPLE LIKE BILL GATES WHO HAS
BILLIONS, THEY DIE BUT THEY
CONTINUE TO DISTORT OUR SOCIETY
HERE WE SHOULD TAX THEM
IMMEDIAT